what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
we're here hey
so as usual we'll start with the topic
and then dive into q a and zayn will
keep the show rolling uh
when i i gotta pop it at 2 25. so the
topic was from mark elwood hey now
last blast from how long have we known
each other mark i think uh go back to
2006 or seven so 13 years at least
i remember when i first met you at a
starbucks and you brought your time
coder machine and you're kind of
introducing mark mark there's time
studies time tracking we
there it is he that's what the third
generation fourth generation
yep
they spent a lot he made that he made
he's got how many of those 500 how many
do you have with those yeah 400 okay hey
my memory is not that bad good
that one got lost in the lobby by fedex
a little while ago oh well that's fine
one or like a shipment no just one okay
that's not the end of the world anyway
mark does productivity and time studies
but but this question is about
encouraging return visitors to the
website for make me a poem so
um well well it's good that you're here
so we can kind of workshop it uh
can people do the ideas that they're
gonna make their own poem and then share
it with you what's the concept well
here's the deal yeah you
i don't want this to be all about me so
i'll just do this briefly and then you
can talk about websites in general for
those who are in that kind of business
so just very briefly
everyone do try this afterwards because
i'd like your input
makempom.com you go there and you can
create your own poems just by filling
out some questionnaires and for those of
you who are into self development
there's one on motivate yourself to get
more done there's one on uh getting
yourself out of a slump and you can do
one for your
partner your love partner and others
after one free poem then you're asked to
register there's no payment yet so i'm
interested in getting your feedback
collectively uh so
makemeappoem.com it's fun it's really
kind of neat try the one for kids too
there's sound effects and pictures
so um we've i've just started four weeks
ago we launched the registration two
days ago
people are making about 30 poems a day
we're getting five or six sign ups a day
so evan that's enough of that you can
talk to the group generally about
attracting people to your website about
gamification about uh getting
monetizing a website it doesn't have to
be just about me you can talk in general
terms cool yeah and listen welcome
everybody uh i made this group so that
people who've read the book can get
value
and
actually start to execute in the ideas
so we do this every week uh either me if
i'm here or zayn when when i'm not
because it's important that you actually
take action and don't just have another
book sitting on your shelf
what i love doing in any kind of
business model is trying to figure out
how do i get people to come back in
terms of how do you incorporate this
into a regular routine so
you know the idea of make me poem is
great and just looking at the at the
website uh i think
expressing why this matters like why
should i do a poem would be helpful
so you get the cases of motivate
yourself or write a love letter to your
partner but something something about
the the importance of it
people don't default to thinking poems
like i don't remember the last time i
wrote a poem at all so uh i may not be
good with words so they've written some
books so i don't know but but having
that
be something aspirational of
why poems are important and they could
be famous quotes from people talking
about poems uh the the value of having
connections all that kind of stuff but
so the why and then how do we build how
do we build what we do and this is
beyond the website it's for everybody
you're trying to build your movement how
do you build what you do into somebody's
routine
so if i'm
if writing the poem is the thing how do
we incorporate a weekly poem or a daily
poem or 30-day poem challenge to find
the 30 people that we're most grateful
for in our life and send them a poem and
we don't know how to do it so that we've
got this great tool to help us figure
out how to do this
right so giving giving it
some kind of challenge or some kind of
opportunity to help it build into their
calendar
maybe it's the charges even afterwards
so do a five-day challenge or seven-day
challenge of picking five to seven
people that you want to recognize in
your life
and so i'm coming back and i'm doing
that every day and then at the end of
that challenge then you have the option
to pay and upgrade and membership or
whatever else
um
i think the more you can incorporate
that so you know for me i have we're
doing a series right now on our main
channel the billionaire mindset series
it's a 30-day challenge where every day
for 30 days
we're
showcasing knowledge from billionaires
so you want you want to think like a
billionaire for 30 days
join a challenge right there's an email
sign up there's a pdf calendar companion
calendar that goes along with it it's
all free but gets people
into the system so you have your first
poem for free great
what i see it as oh this is a cool
one-off
because there's nothing that's hooking
me to want to come back
so that challenge of
if you said think of the seven people
that you're most grateful for in your
life and you want to recognize them
and then you're giving me prompts like
your spouse your boss your employees
your team your family give me a list of
100 people that i could think of your
high school friend the guy you met in
the starbucks in 2006 you know
those kinds of things yeah on that
briefly uh the next one i'm thinking
about is one on appreciation you may
only have one lover in your life but
you've got a lot of people to appreciate
so that's probably the next one the next
poem that i'm gonna build
yeah or or i mean some of these might be
for yourself right i mean you said the
first one is motivation for yourself so
pick one for yourself pick one for
people in your life pick one for
friends i think the more you can involve
other people too i think it's especially
valuable if i write a poem for myself it
may not feel as powerful as i write a a
love poem to zayn
[Laughter]
you know and even even if it's a funny
one
it's going to get a reaction right and
then oh now that zayn saw it he's gonna
give me something back and it's gonna
reinforce the the feedback loop like oh
this is this is cool
um evan
you mentioned the word challenge is that
the sort of the new gamification we
talked about getting badges and things
way back but now you're talking about
challenges
what that's evolved to
um yeah i mean gamification still isn't
it's not dead you can still have
challenge badges and points and all that
stuff it's kind of complicated to
set up versus if i came here
and i signed up for something that's
seven days instead of just a one-off and
i know in your head it's not a one-off
the idea is people come here all the
time and keep doing this as part of the
regular routine but if i'm landing on
this page i just feel like it's a
one-off that i might do for somebody and
so that's that's the challenge for you
is to say no this is something that
you should be doing regularly and here's
here's how you get started so you make
it super easy to get started so give me
a list of seven people one is for
yourself i would probably do like day
seven the last one for myself
i want to involve other people as soon
as possible if i made a love poem for
nina and she freaks out that's gonna
that's gonna reinforce my belief that
this is valuable
and i'm gonna come back the next day and
do something else
so
but people need help just like they need
help right in the poem they need help
thinking of who to send this to
so i need a list of types of people
right
load your high school yearbook and find
somebody you know like you can give a
list of a hundred different kinds of
people that you could send a poem to
and then that becomes a challenge for
the next seven days um is it sent
through your system
or they have to send it themselves
we can we can build something we're
talking about building something where
we would email the poem to someone okay
right now you just download it yourself
got it um
yeah so even if even if they put in
their email address like have they have
the poem emailed to you
that if i type it in then the poem gets
emailed to me now you have my email
address so that you can send me future
stuff
um
i think yeah i think it'd be valuable so
i mean it's for everybody too whether
you're doing poems or something else
somebody's landing on your piece of
content how do you hook them to want to
join you for
a set number of days because if i'm
coming back every day doing something
for a week i'm much more likely to stick
i'm much more likely to talk about it
and the more you can involve somebody
else on day one
versus motivate yourself to get stuff
done like i'm going to send a
a letter a poem of appreciation to
mark ellwood and he writes back says how
amazing that is the more you can connect
people together the better
one of the new things i'm doing to
movement makers so
if you join movement makers we've
created a new onboarding sequence where
you join movement makers
uh i send you a video dm to say hey
welcome to moviemaker so excited to have
you can't wait to have your next
training i'm following you back on
instagram
welcome aboard um somebody just wrote
back today to say
i can't believe you sent that personal
message i'm in tears i appreciate you so
much like that took me 12 seconds to
send that video dm
but she's already a lot more interested
in what we're doing what happens in next
week is i'll then send another video dm
to introduce them
to the men i sent to xan
and the woman i sent angela
so
uh a new woman joins i say hey susan
welcome to overmakers again i want to
quickly introduce you to angela angel's
in the group she's been with us forever
she's awesome i want you to connect on a
quick zoom call one so that you don't
feel alone when you come to movement
makers your first meeting you're not
by yourself you have somebody to connect
with and two just to help you get the
most out of the program
she can answer any questions it's not a
sales pitch you're already in but she
can help answer any questions you've got
on how to get the most out of this
membership and so that's a that's maybe
you know three videos takes me a 45
seconds to say that message and send so
now they have somebody else they both
have somebody else that they know so
that when they join movie makers some
people are stressed out overwhelmed like
oh my god did i do the right thing but
then they see zayn like oh yeah i talked
to zan last week he was amazing i can't
wait to go on
it's not just
me they're hearing from it's somebody
else who's already in the community and
so the faster you can get
connection to others beyond just you
it increases adoption it increases the
habit so
back to the poem website the first thing
i would love to do is have
my first poem be to whoever the most
important person is in my life
and maybe that's my i mean for me it'd
be nina but it could be
my parents it could be my my my children
it could be my partner if it's pick
somebody like who's the most important
person in your life and that's the first
poem that i send and hopefully get a
little emotional doing it and they get a
little emotional in receiving it and now
we've created
a new habit loop that we want people to
jump into
cool
good topic good topic okay what else we
got we still got we got still got some
time before zane takes over what do you
guys got
good question evan
yep
uh
views on youtube you and i talked about
this before with my youtube channel i
have a utility channel yep teaching
people how to pass driving exams
yes yes
we're just about to hit 200 000
subscribers wow look at that congrats 30
million views we're honing in on 30
million views awesome
so just a quick overview so since i'm
not really after subscribers i've
i'm in the seo game as you've said which
was the light bulb going on in my life
in your life wow okay great
well it was it was like well in which is
my business right my business life i
guess yeah
um
so what's a quick overview of how to get
more views how to get more eyeballs on
my videos in youtube without getting
subscribers
it's all about the keywords for you so
uh
were you i'm trying to remember were you
doing
by state or was it just generic that's
what i'm working on right now is the
state stuff i'm yeah it took me a little
while to get going on that but i'm
currently implementing that so we're
going after those keywords of how to
pass the driver's test in california
texas florida yeah
yeah so definitely definitely the big
the big states first
and then working your way down to
all of them um i don't know if it
matters for
for cities
like i would i would go and let me just
type this in so you're smart
smart drive drive test yes okay let me
find you smart drive test the other
thing i've done recently with videos
because i put one video up a week
i've been going to my
competitors yeah
and looking at their most
uh
their most popular videos yep and doing
those topics and that's been
that's been
successful
so how to pass the road test
so yeah so i mean it's popping up bc
alberta for me because i'm canadian
that's what it's funny that that's
showing up before ontario which is my
state
so
looking at this right you have new york
and then you have ny
road test in 3d driving class i don't
even know what that is i don't know if i
want to know what that is it's like a
simulator yeah do you do that do you
cover that too oh i don't cover
simulators i don't think that i my
personal opinion is they don't work
okay well you can you can make a video
on that um so these are the big like new
york massachusetts florida georgia in
minnesota like you're taking these exact
keywords but then the next level down is
stuff like this like how to pass the
road test in wayne new jersey
okay
and there may be no difference you know
like what's the difference between wayne
new jersey and new jersey
could be exactly the same thing right
but from a search perspective this is
this is weird advice
it's something that most of you
shouldn't follow because rick as much as
he's got 200 000 subscribers actually
doesn't care about subscribers this is a
pure
seo play so the keywords matter
um so you know if i type that in i don't
know what shows up
like this guy has
385 000 views on this video with 600
subscribers yeah
i don't know what ra
raw way is is that is that a city in new
jersey
i
i don't know
i haven't heard of that now i'm curious
i get to dive into all these
yeah it's in new jersey right so because
he made this video like this should be
you
okay he made this video that put rahway
in the title and he's got
385 000 views on this nothing channel
just because i put in wayne new jersey
that vid but that video evan is also
five years old that's fine
so but like you said we could definitely
do that yeah i mean but there'll be lots
like rahway seems to be
you know a title it's interesting
um yeah that's fine that it's old uh
it's still it's still being recommended
yeah yeah no you're you're absolutely
correct and and the beautiful thing is
like has things changed that much in the
past five years that really warrants a
new video probably not the only thing
that's changed in the last five years is
backup cameras
okay so
great this is why this video is still
crushing for them
this guy's business probably isn't even
let's see what is he doing
oh he's doing he's doing some other
videos so he's teaching people how to
drive a lot of these are too short
50 seconds one minute
um but yeah so
i mean we just found this because i put
how did how to pass the road test
and then that popped up
so
you just said these are too short what
do you mean by too short
i'd be looking at i mean for him at
least five minute videos if not
eight to ten to twelve minute videos
explaining
you can even repurpose a lot of the
content rick
yes
slightly different videos like hey if
you're i would start with the thing if
you're looking to pass your test in
wayne new jersey i'm going to show you
how in this video and then the rest is
the same video
[Laughter]
because it's all the same stuff like
it's it's new jersey
but but you hook me in the beginning
where this thumbnail says uh
wayne
wayne new jersey on the thumbnail and
you say that in the intro
and then that's a different enough video
for youtube as long as there's something
slightly different
all i redo is just re-shoot the
20-second intro
yeah now if there's actually difference
between new jersey and california then
fine then then
you know there's there's again it's a
slight difference
the only difference is they don't
parallel park in california they back up
50 feet along the curb so that's the
only difference
right so
you could be popping out
20 videos a day all on different
cities
and then when somebody's searching
you're gonna you're gonna be the guy
that shows up because they're searching
for their own they feel like wayne new
jersey is different
even though you know that it's not they
don't know that it's not
so this is this is the other piece that
i have planned evan as soon as this
copic thing is over and i can go back to
the states
i'm going to just travel to the top 10
states
in the us and i'm going to do a driver's
video in each one of those states and
then i can like you just said i can
repurpose each one of those videos
to nail all 50 states
yeah but i mean you could you could
start now
and just do a version two
okay
just timing uh evan did you think that
you need eight to twelve minutes to
teach someone properly or are you
talking about the uh youtube algorithms
and algorithms
yeah i mean it's algorithm it doesn't
matter so much for rick because he's
going so long tail that
like i put in wayne new jersey and and
the rahway new jersey video popped up
because youtube's smart enough to know
that
rahway is close to
wayne somehow right
there's not enough there's not enough
people making content so
you could probably win with shorter
videos but in general if you're making
longer videos it does it does better on
youtube i would i would make i would
it's not just to teach it's to actually
rank better in the algorithm so what are
you aim for uh evan on yours
we're going for an hour
oh okay yeah like we're going long but i
would say at least 10 minutes and what's
great about rick's thing is
it's the same video so you could you
could do it you could do a 10 minute
video make it really good or 15 20
minute video make it really good people
will watch if you're teaching them step
by step like put put an effort into
really making it
good like the best thing and there
there's not a lot of good quality anyway
on it so it's not that hard to be the
best but i would hire a videographer
come with you make it high quality
and then you could even just cut pieces
if you just took some
some
random streets that doesn't look like
anywhere you don't have to be in
california it could just it could be
anywhere it's some random street where
you don't see the street signs and oh
that doesn't look like wayne new jersey
or whatever it's just totally could be
any any city in america any side street
um and then film there and make that
your base and then if you have to splice
in or out content around okay well
california we're gonna do parallel
parking and that gets cut in
and you're gonna take that part out for
new
jersey the other thing evan just on that
comment about longer videos yeah i was
looking at one of my competitors this
morning
their most popular video was an hour and
14 minutes
oh yeah people are live
that's just going over multiple choice
questions for the learner's test yep
and it's got almost a million views in
one year
yep
i'm like okay i need to do this video
right and then do it by state even even
if it's the exact same questions people
will think it's different because
they're going to youtube to find
yeah
i don't know what it is weird about that
what the mental block i have about that
doing the exact same video but saying
this is for new jersey this is for
california i i have some mental block
with that i don't know what it is
maybe it's my upper limit problem
no
you're you're just flip with the service
you're helping people this is what
people are searching for
and there's not enough content on it
the
the good news is you don't have to
make it fancy or because there's not a
lot of content out there on this people
aren't really committed to doing it so
you could win with just you could just
be you could sit there like your
background area looks beautiful you look
like you know what you're doing a guy
who's obsessed with driving obviously by
just looking at your background
so you could even just sit there and do
it especially those multiple choice ones
oh yeah totally
yeah and just splash up a new jersey
something on the side like you know put
it on in the editing
it's giving the value to the consumer
they're searching for it you want to
give it to them yeah and then that
promotes what you're ultimately selling
a course right or a program pass your
driver's desk first time
yeah
so again for this it's totally different
than most youtube advice i would give
because people don't want to subscribe
and you already got 200 000 subscribers
but people don't why am i going to
subscribe to a how to drive
like it's a moment in time for people's
lives oh no exactly no you're spot on
you're spot on because they're there
sort of six to eight weeks
you know 80 of them and then they're
gone
yeah the only people who would really
subscribe and watch are other driving
school teachers who want to see the
latest content that you're coming up
with so even if somebody does subscribe
great a year later they're not watching
the content anymore hopefully because
they passed the test
although i failed my driving test i
think five times
so i could have used your program
there's always something not the written
i aced the written the actual driving i
got too nervous and i just messed up a
bunch of times and i could have used
your help and guidance on that
but again i would have put i wouldn't
have trusted you like oh this guy's from
where is he from
oh he's american okay you can't help me
yeah right i would have typed ontario
not knowing that it's probably pretty
much the same across canada
awesome thank you lady lexi also failed
her driver's test so there you go
perfect i don't feel sorry
cool you only you only fail if you
give up
and don't go and get your license if you
got your life you didn't fail you were
just unsuccessful at that attempt
i i
i failed
to the point where on my last one i
failed and then they they gave me an ex
uh
my next test was going to be past the
expiry date of my
my whatever my like my license is going
to expire but my test was afterwards so
they gave me a temporary license just
for that day
so i could drive there and do the do the
exam and luckily i passed that and i've
never been in like accidents or tickets
or anything like i'm a great driver i
don't know why i couldn't it was
anxiety or pressure of having somebody
with me that's evan was it in toronto
uh well i went a little outside the city
i learned because
they're they're a lot harder in the big
city where if you go a little outside
they're nicer and friendlier sorry i
slowly learned
know what else i learned a couple of
weeks ago was that if you go to toronto
the test is probably only 10 minutes
it's like if you go to new york city
it's only eight minutes
whereas if you go to someplace outside
the city that's a small town they got
all the time in the world your test
would be like 45 minutes long
okay well i mean i passed outside the
city so i'll take that they were nicer
but i could have used all your hacks
luckily i got my test
and uh i'm 41 and don't have to worry
about doing that again but even when i
get to my 70s and i'm forced to
take them again then i'll
actually when you're 80 you have a
mandatory test yeah
that could be another that's another
category like
seniors and and also like kids of the
seniors trying to research how do i help
my 80 year old
father or grandfather pass this test if
there's any specifics around that i'd
look at that as content too
i'm so excited because we got jeff and
uh we're putting him on the spot so what
do you got jeff how can i help
man i got a lot of things coming in the
pipe uh
you know life and detours and things i
had to walk out of work so i could take
this while i'm on lunch i plan my whole
day around being here today because uh
the detours is really what my life has
been about for the last few years and
having things happen that i've not
expected unexpected but to embrace them
and to travel with it i'm going to be
quitting my job in the next couple of
weeks there we go wow
wow
yeah i'm putting the two weeks notice in
probably within the next five days
i know quitting your job is a big
freaking deal i'm sorry to jump in real
quick how can we support you
man i'm not like i have the plan in
place right now i mean there's gonna be
a lot more time for me to reach out and
actually get
networking again with all the people i
used to have but with life you know
taking over and having them i have no
place to live right now i'm living in my
rv but that's almost sold next week so
that's going to be done and i have a new
job that's going to take me all over the
country so it's going to be but it's
going to give me plenty of time to
create videos and share those moments
and share all the things i've done
before
or seen before but this time i can
document it okay keep your eyes on the
road as you go man you're making me
nervous
oh i'm good now i'm good now
okay what do you got how can i help man
what do we got
okay so i've been watching a lot of the
uh
the traveling truck drivers and i'm
going to be getting my cdl again i did
drive from the time i was 21 to 27 and i
was older a truck driver um i have a
position available where i'm going to
be basically running
about five different dedicated routes
and it's a one big loop i'm going to
live in the truck for the next six
months to a year and just take all of my
vacations everywhere i'm at um
and it's gonna still be detours i'm
trying to find new unique locations but
this is just gonna put me nationwide
so wherever they send me it's gonna be a
new thing um
you know
i know i'm doing a little bit of a shift
again for the 15th time
but
i think that's what my audience is used
to and everything so selling it
shouldn't be that big of a deal um how
fast let's i'll ask this question how
fast should i concern myself with
anything but the content so like swag or
trying to work on a website or trying to
work on should i should i even dedicate
anything to that or should i just
basically get super consistent and study
on that for three to six months and then
go from there yeah i would i would i
would definitely focus on just getting
content up
um i don't even care if your audience is
used to it or not
because you're not going back to who you
were before
so
you know that's that's that's the prison
that a lot of people put themselves in
is like oh i have to keep doing what i
was doing because that's what people
expect of me is like okay well
you know you're not that person you're
gonna hate your life more and more and
more if you keep trying to be that
person so whether your audience you know
whatever your audience is now whether
they like it or not it doesn't matter
because it's who you are so the ones who
would like that will join you and the
ones who don't cool
but go follow somebody else we got we'll
send them to zane and
and they'll attract a whole bunch of new
people in as well
um
content for sure i wouldn't i wouldn't
stress out too much about swag and
anything else especially if it's part of
the business model like if you want to
wear if you want
merch for yourself to wear and then that
might turn into something cool
but uh you know
the monetizing off of clothing isn't is
just that's not where a lot of money is
you know it's not that's not the game
you know blog
should it be something or still content
over everything for six months and then
take it from there
well blog would be if you actually enjoy
writing
i've done it so many times i've i do
enjoy it and i think it there's a spot
for it that could fit out there but i
don't know i haven't done it
consistently to know if i'm gonna like
it or not but it's something i should
even
i'm just trying to not overwhelm myself
over the next six months and i think the
most important is content i just kind of
want backing on that
stay consistent on the content
and then whatever else comes you can
explore and have some fun with but don't
make it this giant pressure on yourself
like we need jeff and his message and
the detours getting out there to the
world because even with the content it's
been like start and stop and start and
stop and here we go and then and then
where he's gone for what you know and
then he starts again so it's great
now let's get consistent and and take
people on the journey so even even in
the process of you quitting your job
like it can start it can start now you
could start in your car right now like
guys i'm doing something new
i'm quitting my job
my two weeks notice because i'll get
fired that's the only reason but no no
you can you can film it now
and then don't release it until two
weeks
well see now right there i didn't even
i'm i'm yeah i don't even know why i
didn't even think of that it's just
holding that
here's what you need to do like if you
honestly if you just created a schedule
where at the beginning at least every
week a video every week a video every
week a video right and then hopefully
we're having like multiple videos coming
up every week but
if you force yourself to say okay i have
to make a video this week
then you'll you would come up with that
idea
and you come up with much better ideas
you'll come up with all sorts of insane
ideas because that's how your brain is
genius when you direct it
right
i go every direction all at once and
that's always been my problem since the
day i met you was focus
you're giving yourself the out like
that's the thing you got to stop giving
yourself the out like a video has to be
recorded oh but i'm not quitting my job
for two weeks or whatever i haven't put
in my notice so that's the out so it's
okay now you don't have to produce right
there's always going to be some out
that you'll convince yourself and not
just you this is this applies to lots of
creators that we convince ourselves that
we're not going to do i don't feel
creative today i'm tired i didn't sleep
well last night like oh i ran out of gas
in the truck it was really rough day
like there's always
if we wait for the perfect time it's
never the time and we always give
ourselves the out so like stop giving
yourself the out and then your brain
will
we're using it in a creative way to help
you make what you need to make
it's like every week a video has to be
recorded
and then inside of that you'll you'll
find you'll make some amazing things
never put up a zero says andrew there
you go i i saw that no more zeros and
the funny thing is even at the car
dealership that's on our board it says
never never a day with a zero
so
and listen even if the video doesn't
always fit into the format right like
that's where give yourself the
permission to detour maybe you're going
in and
today's video you're trying out a new
restaurant that you've never tried
before you've never done a restaurant
review or you're you're rescuing some
raccoon on the side of the road and like
what i don't know what it is like this
is where you
you you can have fun with it and be
creative like within the constraint of i
have to make a video
this week
but then what kind of video
you might have a format that you like
and you stick to but then every now and
then it's it's being willing to shift
from it because if you only did the same
kind of video every time too you're
going to start going crazy just knowing
you like you're going to have to shake
it up and do it i know the privilege of
is i know what seven years on the road
did for me a long time back and i know
the freedom i had and the time i had
because i had so much extra time i did
so many things and now knowing what i
know about documenting
it's i get to show the world what i
loved about trucking for seven years and
what and it's not even really trucking
what i loved about traveling and and
being out there and meeting new people
and
just experiencing life and that's
you don't always know where life's going
to take you but you know you never know
where life's going to take you uh no but
that's it and like imagine if you had
just started if you would start if you
had filmed those seven years and stay
consistent on doing that like you'd be
in a totally different spot right now
and then the point of that is not to
make you feel bad and say hey you suck
jeff it's to use that as fuel going
forward to say okay like if i film the
next three years of my life doing i'm
going to be in a totally different spot
is going to be wild and different like
maybe you're doing coaching calls and
talking and doing interviews like you
have your podcast and you're you're
interviewing elon musk from your truck
as you're driving to texas or whatever
like who knows like you're gonna you're
gonna come with some wild stuff that's
just gonna happen but
you don't
ask me he asked me point blank about six
weeks ago
uh
the one thing you kind of not regret but
if you could make better and i was like
i wish i could have documented the seven
years on the road and he's like that was
your answer to if you if you should go
take this new job with your sister or if
not and and that was kind of my
yep that's okay all this time i've been
waiting for this moment and june 30th
was my date i'm a little delayed on it
but that's okay but
i'm like yeah that's it i have the
position available to me if i want it
and
you know now it's that was my biggest
regret life is to be able to see all
this stuff but never be able to share it
so you're documenting the detours but
but how you document and what you
document can change a million times
exactly
i appreciate you so much evan time to
get to work and today needs a video jeff
we need a video today
i'm going to turn this thing sideways
there it is all right i can start
filming right after this or leave this
and go make your video who cares about
this well i'm going to listen i'm going
to listen and eat lunch so i'm going to
listen to you okay good get inspired but
video has to happen today
yes sir all right we love you jeff
tanya's got her hand up tanya hello
everyone uh so i have a question let's
see if i can
can explain myself
so i'm uh working on
my youtube channel and uh
what i want to do with this youtube
channel the the message i want to to
work on is um make people believe that a
radical change in life is possible
and inspire them to initiate their
journey with an immigrant mindset
that means not turning back enjoy the
journey
and give everything you have upon
arrival to live your dream
so
that's that's like my my main my main
motivation let's say
and uh
i thought about i'm doing this list of
people that i want to interview and you
know to start getting get it rolling
but there are many people and many
interesting stories that they are not
necessarily immigrants it's more like an
internal journey because sometimes the
journey is like that sometimes it takes
you to somewhere else
geographically but sometimes it's
internal but when i was recording my
video
then i i was you know i i realized that
i was not
being able to to choose exactly how to
focus it to make it clear what's the
channel about
does it make sense yeah okay so listen
let's um let's let's dance a little bit
with this so this is gonna be fun
first off i love it like you're telling
people to believe in themselves to live
their i mean this is great
yes i love this podcast already use the
magic word
okay so you have a couple options and
and the option that fits best is the one
that's in your heart that's gonna fit
the best right so i'll just pepper them
and you tell me which one resonates
it all really will come down to what you
believe
an immigrant to be so it could be
immigrant physically like what most
people would think immigrant being like
hey you're in canada born somewhere else
you're coming here exposing a new
country cool
um that's a that's kind of that feels
like the limitation you're being stuck
on right now like well what if they
weren't an immigrant to the country but
they still have have
overcome obstacles and objections
so you could stick to that
view traditionally what an immigrant
looks like
the next path out is immigrant mindset
so
what does immigrant mindset mean well if
it's like
hard work and hustle and no excuses and
like whatever you think make up the
immigrant mindset
that could apply to a lot more people
even though they may not be an immigrant
by the textbook definition but they have
the immigrant mindset that you recognize
and you want to bring people on for
that's still like
that's a little bit of a leap it's not a
big leap but it's it's a little bit of
leap from where you were
the the bigger leap out is then
recognizing that everybody's an
immigrant
like if you're trying to build a new
life
separate from what your family is
right like this is what i grew up and
what my parents taught me and i want to
build a different life and i wind up in
a different spot i'm an immigrant in
those situations
in in jeff taking on this new challenge
in his life is like unless his dad was a
trucker and documented his journey he's
saying no
then jeff is
him having the courage to quit his job
and go trucking and document it is is
living in an immigrant life
because he's trying to build something
brand new that's never been done before
for him and what he's used to
so they're like leaving a country and
going to another country is basically
what jeff is doing even though he's in
the us and he's not like an immigrant by
textbook definition so
it all depends on how you want to define
immigrant
and how much you want to stretch it
from a textbook only i'm only going to
bring people who are like physically
immigrant to the to the country to
immigrant mindset and whatever that
means to you to then recognizing that
everybody's actually if you're on a
growth path everybody in the world is an
immigrant how much do you want to
stretch it what feels right
like where is the answer for you
i would say that
the
everybody is an immigrant it's very
appealing
like
we all have this journal journeys right
whoever makes a journey immigrates from
one state to others so that's definitely
very appealing
now i think that
a central point of uh what i would like
to stress is the immigrant mindset
and uh that also kind of like focus on a
specific specific type of of of
people that you know would be interested
in doing this so it's a yeah it's
in my mind yes i would like to include
people not necessarily immigrant by the
textbook i don't want to limit myself to
that because i i just know so many
amazing people who have not immigrated
geographically but have made these
journeys
so i would like to stay
there like
not not like because
part of
the content that i want to put out is
people you know sharing their decision
how they got to the decision what was
the initial state
they journey how the journey was you
know for them the arrival and also to
share
to share kind of like tips and tricks
kind of clues on how they became
successful
in in doing this
so
yeah so that yes that's just on you then
to pull that out and make it make sense
for the audience so let me use zayn as
an example and i'm going to share two
zen examples because we just love zayn
uh
zen had a very successful career in the
music industry
right
like djing huge events you you he's got
pictures with some of the world's most
famous people that he doesn't share and
show off because he's a humble guy and
we love him but but he was like top of
his game in the dj world
and
he decided to go into coaching
and when he did that people like what
are you doing dude what you've like had
it made here you're hosting the biggest
part is you're in vegas you're going to
coaching like this is not a smart move
right
so zen then had zen became an immigrant
in the coaching world
he had to leave his home his country
where he had had so much comfort and
community and connection and then moved
to a new country called coaching
and then he started getting
certification he started joining
programs and he started connecting with
people so that that the new country
became his his new country that he felt
welcome and accepted and became a leader
in his new country so he took the
immigrant path to make that happen
instead of staying in in just a comfort
right um and so
zane can talk to that mindset and i'm
i'm summarizing this story he can go in
a lot deeper if you want to interview
him for your show but
that's a great example of the immigrant
mentality even though xan
was born and raised in the u.s and has
never left
i guess he left the cold country and
went to vegas and now doesn't have to
worry about winter coats and snow and
anything anymore
but it's that immigrant mindset
um
one of my favorite conversation with zan
was talking about how
everything is coaching
it's like what is coaching saying he's
like oh well like you're having a
session you're coaching somebody and you
you tell them what to do and then they
go off and do it like okay well like if
the goal
is to get somebody to take action right
the goal is for them to
come into your space and then they go
home and they do something to change
their life
you can accomplish that like that's
coaching cool but you can accomplish
that in so many more ways than just a
speech or just a one-on-one session like
when somebody and i know this goes up
you know from the salsa dancing world
when somebody comes into an event that
we would host where there's a great dj
in playing music have they ever left
that event
feeling happier
and then going off and deciding to make
some life change
yeah does it happen for everybody maybe
not but some people walk in to a club
listen to a dj
have a great time and then go home and
decide to quit their job or marry that
person or start a youtube channel or go
trucking or whatever right it's like you
made that happen
you made that you were playing even
though you never met them
they may not have come up to you and
told you what happened as a result the
vibe that you brought the energy that
you brought like zan brings so much care
and love and energy into the thing
everything that he's doing so when he's
pouring that into music you made that
vibe happen you set up the scenario for
them to go home and then take that big
life choice you made that happen that
was you that's coaching
it's just expanding the definition of
what is coaching me
and so the same thing with uh you know
what is an immigrant
a lot of people can relate to the you
know the struggles of starting something
new and leaving the comfort of of home
behind to then go off and do it and so
you know that that's where i default to
living so like if that's where you want
to to play it really broadens the
spectrum of the kinds of people that you
can bring on you just have to be
intentional with how you bring that
story out to say hey you know you you
were an immigrant moving from
you didn't move to new country but you
moved from the entertainment industry
into coaching zayn anything you want to
add to that i shared a lot and
summarized but you know it's your story
no everything you say is amazing it's
just i i mean what a talent to be able
to take something
and and and make it fit and make it so
relevant
i just i'm i'm sitting here just like
this guy is so talented
he can sum it up and make it relevant i
mean just that's a talent man i'm still
learning i'm still uh evan and i and one
part i will add is that evan
has deepened and widened
my understanding of what a coach is when
a coach does
and uh it's because of him that i have a
such a deep understanding
of of who i am as a coach and and how
could be a blessing and a service and
value to other people but yeah evan what
a talent man
i mean i remember zen used to host my
gaming stream with me so we got into a
lot of discussions key to discussions
sometimes around these things but i mean
in the early zayn was like i can't coach
women i just can't coach women you know
and now some of us the best people in
coaches are women he said well there's
coaching in this therapy but i'm never
going to do therapy like that's not what
i do and then he goes to get certified
in cognitive behavior therapy right and
but like it's not um
if anything is a credit to zayn is like
he's willing to go and expand the
definition and explore and so when i
said at the beginning of this time he
was like well let's see how much you
want to let's play
and let's let's have a dance let's see
how far you want to go with this because
you could stick to the textbook
definition and we can just stay there or
we can expand the definition which will
give you a lot more
creativity and more fun and and amazing
things can happen and you're already
feeling the restriction like i want to
have these people on but it doesn't fit
the mold of what an immigrant is and the
more you can play and expand that the
more value you can bring people yeah
definitely thank you thank you so much
yeah that i guess is indeed your biggest
gift open people's minds so i am really
really um starting to think like yes uh
there there is no need to restrict
um in the sense of you know people
actually
if there's so much uh room
to
you know to bring more interesting
people if i don't restrict the concept
of of the channel like leave it open and
just
play around uh what it's to immigrate
from one state
of mind or you know physically to other
and all the the adventure that it
includes
this is this is classic like heart heart
versus head decision making
like your heart wants to bring these
people on your show but your head
doesn't understand how to do it
and whenever they're battling like that
it's like the heart is always right like
these people need to be on your show
you just haven't figured out the how and
the structure around it yet because it
doesn't make sense but but they have to
like you don't want to not have they
have to be on your show or you're going
to regret it
right yes same thing with jeff going on
his detours and trucking and quitting
like he has to do it he has to do it if
he doesn't do it he's going to regret it
again in the next seven years but the
how of like who it's going to change
what is it a document is going to change
it's going to be all over the place and
if you judge yourself like oh i didn't
make it exactly the same as last time
then you're staying small as opposed to
doing the thing that's like out of this
amazing things will be born
yeah i think so
so whenever like i mean thank you and
what i love about utahn is you you
you show up and you ask questions and
you like admit what you're what you're
working through it's great like i would
have been too afraid
at the start of my journey it was my
biggest thing as i never asked for help
i didn't even know how to ask for help i
felt i should know the answers um so
you know
kudos to you because i probably wouldn't
have been here at the year at the start
of my journey so um i love how you ask
for help
and and are open to the feedback and
then you go do something with it it's um
really inspiring but whenever whenever
it's like i want to do something it
feels so right but it doesn't make sense
whenever they're fighting head in the
heart the heart's always right
and so you have to tell the brain okay
well we're going to make this make sense
somehow so let's get on board and make
it happen
right like if we had jeff had to make a
video every week
he'll find a way to make it happen
he'll just he'll be creative and make it
if you had to make that happen you have
to bring these people on the show you'll
find a way to make it happen and you did
by even coming here and posing a
question
yeah the brain will find a solution to
follow the heart so it's like
heart first when your heart's telling
you do something you have to go you have
to have to have to have to do it and
then your brain will help you figure out
the how
yeah and it it was so hard like it's
it's i feel it's so hard like it you
know it's just that i i i had to ask
because i had this you know inside and i
had to ask
so so to give it yeah like to be able to
because i i recorded so many videos and
it was not feeling right how to do it so
you know i have to ask even though it's
you know
saying something that still not yet
there and it's kind of like pressure but
i didn't wanted to keep it to myself so
thank you so much for i love and listen
for everybody too like bring it up bring
it up sooner when it's in your heart you
feel it but you can't often bring words
to it and it doesn't make sense and like
you haven't you haven't crystallized the
thought properly yet because your head
doesn't understand it so if your head
doesn't understand you can't communicate
it very well but you just use the best
words that you can to get it out there
and in magical things
will start to happen um anyway huge
credit to you we love you tanya thank
you for sharing thank you for showing up
the movie makers and being here let's
see ej's got our hand up what do we got
hey there thanks for being here today i
had
i get really excited about doing content
and then just as i'm ready to do it i'm
like oh everything follows it in my head
i get really scared i just and then
nothing comes out or i'll make content
and then i won't post it and so some
suggestions on how to kind of
overcome
that yeah so a couple things to help me
one i still posted it so like expect to
suck and post and and it gets a little
bit better
every time and that that becomes the the
journey and the lesson for other people
watching as well that they see you and
you can even say
i had all this stuff planned and i
totally forgot what i was going to say
and here and then post that you know
like post
get used to posting the imperfections
because that's actually what's really
inspiring um
when i when i broke my neck in 2019 and
still filmed videos all through that and
like like those were not my best videos
but people found it really inspiring
that i would even i wasn't even thinking
that way it's like i still got to make
videos
but people are more inspired by those
videos and than the ones before because
it's just a willingness to show up with
everything that happened i was a worse
version of me than i was before but they
were inspired by the action so lean into
it like it's the it's the difference
between what you
think you're capable of and what you're
capable of in the moment
and so leaning into that to say hey i'm
i forgot everything like if i forgot
that's part of the video
i had this perfect video lined up and
now i'm i forgot everything but here's
what i want and then you go and then you
post and then tomorrow's another video
and the next week's
whatever your cadence is but the next
one's it's happening and it's happening
just to teach yourself that it's okay to
make mistakes and it's okay to not be
perfect and it's okay that
if the microphone breaks halfway through
or the light goes off or you have a leak
in the roof or like whatever i don't
know whatever happens or you just brain
fart and forget you just
just keep going because it's actually a
better skill to learn than to have
everything be perfect
um
the other thing that helps me is is just
tying it
like that's the most important thing
because if you're concerned about
perfection you'll never create anything
but tying it in the service
when i get it out of my head
and into other people
that your message today matters like the
video that you're recording today is not
just about you it's not about your ego
it's not about the follower account it's
like you have something in your heart
that you want to share with people that
can help them like your message can help
somebody maybe it doesn't reach a
million people but it can it can help
somebody
and by you not posting a video you're
cheating the person from the opportunity
to
maybe make a life-changing decision
and whenever it's only about me i play
small
but whenever i can make it about even if
it's a even if it's like made up
right like i used to imagine an
entrepreneur friend of mine he was the
camera so i'm not talking to the camera
i'd imagine him and i'm talking to him
and i'm so it was made up but it felt
like i was doing something that was
meaningful to him at least
and so i i posted and it gave me more
strength and more courage to still show
up in perfect imperfectly like it's it
still won't be perfect you'll never it
took me 750 videos 700 videos sorry
until i was inspired by myself right
where i watched it back like oh
getting good let's go right 700 videos
so i sucked a lot and and we are our own
worst critic
always everybody can relate to that
who's here you know on the call
um so yeah just the permission to be
imperfect and the permission to to suck
and the permission for it not to go well
on permission to it's okay that you lost
your train of thought in the middle of
it because you're nervous
and just say that
and then and then tie it to service so
like hopefully it still helps somebody
and if you could feel that it's helping
somebody it's not about you anymore
it'll give you more courage to show up
i connect like
i resonate so deeply with it because i
struggled so much with it
and i think everybody can connect with
that on some level too if you do it like
i can see doing that once but like you
did 700 you can't say in 700 videos well
you know like
but don't worry about 700 because you'll
get better
you know like like anything else how
long did it take you to ride a bike or
how long you take you to like whatever
skill set you have how long did it take
the first two times versus
you start to get like it's surprising
how quickly you get better at the thing
like how do you do instagram live oh my
gosh and then like oh it wasn't you know
why this is not that bad i could do that
so it's a great it's a great um it's a
great tool that you can use
and maybe in the beginning you're using
it more than others
but you won't you won't fall back on
that tool for 700 videos
right you'll just get better at it it'll
be okay
so don't worry about having a tool that
you have to use every single time
right
okay but even if you did like even if
you use it for the this is how i think
of it now right if you used it say took
you like 50 videos of doing that every
time for 50 like that's a you'll get
there faster but let's say like you were
just the worst and it took you 50 videos
right like just imagine it took you 50
every 50 videos you struggled and
stammered and lost your train of thought
and just completely blanked out deer in
the headlights and you used that same
technique for fifth imagine and then at
51 you got it and you stopped using it
and 50 and then you're on a path now
imagine when your video 200 in
how much better you are and you can go
back and show people guys look at my i
suck so bad look at my first 50 videos i
couldn't even get a word out of my face
for 50 videos
right it becomes like your struggle that
is so painful and overwhelming actually
becomes the inspiration because people
can see a new humanity
and vulnerability and authenticity and
the willing like courage to keep posting
and keep going even though it completely
sucked at the start
so if you have that and you can kind of
project to being on the other side of it
how much of an inspiration are you going
to be for people
to say hey you know what
if she can do it
maybe i can too
and it will probably won't take me 50
videos to get there
that's why i show like the early days of
my youtube stats right
on my website right the first five years
of like if i just shared the first five
years in isolations like this guy sucks
but the fact that then it gets to three
and a half million or whatever it's like
in the looking back how did you keep
going when it was so bad right it's the
same thing what was in my calendar i had
to do it and i focused on service and
and i i released imperfect things so
yeah just a little perspective shift to
say hey you've got
decades ahead of you of of doing this
kind of stuff to be able to show back
your first it won't take you 50. but
even your first three or five or ten or
whatever it's like look at i couldn't
even even if you just press record and
it's you staring into the camera
post
next
what an inspiration to look back and see
right yeah okay cool i did i did a
series of them like a few and then i
just kind of
got in my own head and then i stopped
yeah well
that like we all get in our own head and
stopped like look at the theme of today
jeff got in his own head and stopped
tanya wants to have these people on her
show and got on her own head and like
hasn't done it right it's like
this is a human thing i get in my own
head
and stop
talking about zayn and and what is
coaching got in his own head and stopped
right we all get in our own heads and
stop which is the value of a community
like this and coaches to help kind of
push you through it and say hey you know
what like here's a perspective shift
that you might want to think about that
can help get you to where you need to go
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love